when we made our decision in December of
2017 I kept track of some of those
predictions you're going to have to pay
$5 per tweet you're not going to be
allowed to post on Instagram one of my
favorites the Senate Democratic caucus
Twitter account said the internet will
work one word at a time or one of my
favorites this is the end of the
Internet as we know it I'm Dave Rubin
and this is the Rubin report make sure
that you're subscribed and click the
notification bell otherwise we're just
talking to ourselves over here and
joining me today is the chairman of the
Federal Communications Commission aka
the FCC a GPI welcome to the Rubin
report hey thanks so much for having me
on Dave
I am thrilled to have you here because I
don't know that I've ever had a guest
that probably has more power to do more
things relative to the thing that I do
than you so that's a lot of pressure my
friend a lot of pressure but I hopefully
will be able to quit myself well we
shall see okay before we do anything
else there is a meme of you you are a
hero yes you are a mean person because
you have a giant mug a coffee mug of a
Reese's Pieces logo coffee mug right and
this thing has caught fire on the
internet how did this even come to pass
why do you have this mug it's so random
so about 10 years ago I was up in
Hershey Pennsylvania with my then
girlfriend now wife and I love coffee
I love Reese's peanut butter cups and I
saw this giant mug and I thought oh this
is the perfect mind-meld and so I just
bought it and at our FCC meetings
sometimes they would drag on for a while
and I'm an inveterate coffee drinker so
I just brought this mug down to our
monthly meetings started drinking out of
it and then John Oliver did the skit
about two and a half years ago mock to
the mug and ever since then I've always
getting these emails tweets and whatnot
yeah you and your mug I always think the
mug with the innocent parties I'm gonna
be some collateral damage it's also a
giant it is so I actually measured it
out of six liquid cups like and so I go
through about two cups of those a day
two mugs a day of coffee and so it's a
fair amount of caffeine that's going
through the veins but it's kind of funny
how it's taking on a life of its own all
right well you kept the coffee mug it's
our coffee mug who tried to buy his
coffee mug for the show but it was a
we're on a time crunch so we couldn't
pull it off but ah yes I have brought
you these as pieces just in time for
Halloween yes Halloween so I'll just put
that there and if you so choose to eat a
Reese's throughout the interview feel
free no I could take it intravenously if
I could go but no I hope you don't mind
if I maybe take a break every now and
then just start munching on it that's
fine okay so there's a ton of stuff I
want to talk to you about obviously I've
never been more sure that either YouTube
is going to completely crush this
episode in the algorithm or make sure
that everyone sees it too thus prove
that they don't mess around with things
so I want to spend obviously a lot of
time talking about tech your regulation
and all that know a little bit about
your history and what the FCC was set
out to do versus what it does now and
all of those things but sort of broadly
to start how much time do you guys now
have to spend
I'm just purely the tech issues related
to censorship rather than just pretty
much anything else that the FCC has ever
done it's a decent amount of time not so
much because we directly regulate them
under the current law we don't have
authority to regulate some of the
Silicon Valley tech giants but in part
because we do regulate broadly speaking
the infrastructure of the internet and
issues like net neutrality of course
have been at the fore for a couple of
years so we're gonna talk about still
works but so we do monitor a lot of
these issues that have come up and it's
a fascinating how much the conversation
has changed when I started talking about
this two years ago it was thought to be
sort of an outlier opinion to go after
some of the Silicon Valley tech giants
for some of the policies or the lack of
transparency in particular and now you
see members of both parties in both
houses of Congress people on the
campaign trail average American consumer
is saying what's going on here we want
more insight into how these companies
are doing business and so we spend a
fair amount of time on that there are
other issues though that occupied the
lion's share of my time 5g closing the
digital divide
attacking unwanted robocalls doing those
kinds of bread and butter attacks that
the FCC has been entrusted with right
okay so let's just back up fully and
what just tell people that have no idea
they hear FCC they're not exactly sure
what it means what it's supposed to do
what was the FCC does
to do originally so it was designed in
1934 to regulate the radio airwaves and
the telephone system the primary means
of communication back then and our
statute is called the Communications Act
of 1934 that Act has been updated over
the years most recently in 1996 in the
substantial part and now our
jurisdiction has grown over the years
it's not just radio and TV and telephone
now of course we have jurisdiction over
satellite issues cable companies to some
extent Internet infrastructure and so
it's composed of five commissioners each
of which has to be nominated by the
president confirmed by the Senate one
Commissioner is designated as a chairman
and that happens to be me right now very
very blessed to be in that position but
there was a huge staff about 1,500
people or so to help us do all of the
work across these different areas and
they do fantastic work from volunteering
to serve in Puerto Rico after Hurricane
Maria to going to tribal reservations in
the Mountain West to help get broadband
to these hard to serve areas and they
are the eyes and ears of the Commission
I've got the top of the pyramid so to
speak but they really deserve all the
credit for the good work we do and you
get involved in the FCC what what made
you the chairman of the FCC honestly a
complete accident I say I became a
lawyer after graduating from college
much my parents chagrin I didn't go to
medical school but if you're trying to
live up that's up for Indian parents was
an interesting conversation I don't have
another lawyer not a doctor
looks like a big hit right I still
remember my graduation party after
college my parents organized a little
party for me in my hometown and one of
my parents friends came and said you
know that's okay it's not everyone can
get into Medical School he's like a nice
little pat on the back and so it's sort
of funny every now and then I try to
explain to my parents that you wondered
as I do and when I told them I was gonna
be nominated for this position by
President Obama back in 2011
my mom's first three questions out of
the gate were is this a full-time job
does it pay and if it doesn't work out
can you go back to the law firm she
still wasn't quite sure what it was they
did but I finally got about thank you
show her the letter from Obama and it's
like is this a full-time job yeah it's a
totally this is a real job but even then
for a while she wasn't sure what I did a
couple years ago I was in LA for some
meetings and was going to see Judge Judy
because I'm you
judi fan and I told my mom and I Friday
hey I'm meeting Judge Judy on a Monday
she canceled all of her patients for
Monday flew down to LA with me and she
got to meet the judge and so and she
never told me afterward but her friends
told me achieved she's so proud of you
that's a great to see judge Judy's like
not getting nominated by the president
not closing the digital light it's Judge
Judy the highest court in the land
getting her into that courtroom that
wasn't accomplished but at the end of
the day it's still about parental
approval yeah yeah yeah so I think the
candle still burns hopefully after this
job's over I think she may want me to go
to medical school but for better or
worse and in this role for now yeah okay
so as the guy in this role can you
explain a little bit about your just
personal philosophy when it comes to
what should be regulated what should be
completely left to the market and where
those two things kind of meet yeah so I
have some basic principles that guide my
work across these different areas that
we've talked about fairly simple
principles but I think they're important
for regulators to keep in mind one is
that markets not preemptive regulation
have delivered far more value for
American consumers over time and number
two the rule of law really matters
administrative agencies like ours can't
just make it up the law has been set by
Congress and passed by an acted by the
president ultimately we can't make a
decision that doesn't have a grounding
in law and third and increasingly
importantly in this field we have to
rest respect basic principles of
economics things might seem like great
ideas but if the cost benefit analysis
doesn't work if the different economic
principles that apply to our work aren't
respected ultimately you will have a
very elegant plan on paper that ends up
foundering on the rocks of reality so we
try to respect those three principles in
everything we do and it's not easy often
times are going to make a lot of people
unhappy but our job at the end of the
day is to deliver value for the American
consumer even when or especially when it
might not be popular does it strike you
that that your job or anyone that's in
government that has anything to do with
regulation that the optics of the job
seem much harder now where am i God you
know 30 years ago is like okay you're
regulating the airwaves there's a couple
channels you know we're on our way to
cable but if you do something like the
pushback is only going to be a certain
amount because it's just how it is
there's only a limit you
get a letter in the mail or something
like that yeah or some phone calls to
your office where now everything that
you guys do and almost anyone that's in
the public eye at any level it becomes
like an absolute firestorm it must it
must complicate the job at a certain
level I think it does and that's
actually a very good point so I've
gotten to know all of my living
predecessors save one going all the way
back to Newton Minow who was President
Kennedy's first FCC Chairman from 61 to
63 I had lunch with him a couple of
years ago I was talking about some of
the things we're working on and how
exposed the job was you know social
media and cable news networks covering
stuff and all the rest and he stopped me
said I don't know how I can do this job
now because back in the 60s we had three
major broadcast channels your local
radio station in your local newspaper
and that was pretty much it it was
satellite hadn't really taken off yet
cable wasn't a real thing and so it's
just a very different job now and that
raises a lot of challenges everything we
do is going to be scrutinized and
there's going to be a lot of commentary
about it and I think it's fair to say
that you are the FCC is much better
known now than it's ever been known
before and then just have some positive
impacts I try to talk about the positive
things we do as well but there's no
question the exposure for this position
for our agency generally has made it a
lot more challenging than it used to be
how much is the the sort of changing
technology kind of affect what you do or
sort of expose the way things were done
in the past so like right now for
example if we were doing this on
television even whether it was network
or cable yeah there's a lot of
limitations to what we could say the
types of things we could show things
like that versus we're doing this on the
internet now we're on YouTube and
podcast so there are some limitations
right but like we can't show porn or
something like that but like pretty much
it's the Wild West out here so you guys
have different rules depending on the
medium how how sort of complicated is
that these days you've put your finger
on one of the central problems in
communications policy is that Congress
sets a little law and that law reflects
a snapshot of the marketplace in a
moment in time and that snap snap shot
especially in the technology sector very
quickly becomes yellowed with age and so
we hear constantly for example from
broadcast TV companies saying look we're
competing the same space with Google and
Facebook and other companies who don't
face the same we're like legacy
regulations that we have to deal with
you need to change that and different
sectors of the economy say the same
thing there's
the problem of government trying to fit
the square peg of the marketplace into
the round hole of the law so what do you
say to those guys when they say that cuz
that's a pretty compelling argument I
think I mean sometimes now you watch
yeah like we have regulations on what
commercials could say be on television
versus the Internet
yeah much anything could be out there so
the way I think about it the one thing I
told my team from the beginning and I've
told them every day since is think about
where the marketplace is right now how
would you construct a regulatory
framework to deal with the marketplace
as it stands today and to the maximum
extent permitted by law we should adjust
our regulations modernize them to
reflect that marketplace and I rely on
one of my favorite political
philosophers I know he's somebody you've
drawn a tremendous amount of wisdom as
well Yoda who in the entire strikes sack
in this training Luke and Decker well
you were made to go in John Locke
willing much more profound than that I
property very important but Yoda when
he's creating yeah and so at one point
when he's training Luke he says you must
unlearn what you have learned and that
is so true when it comes to Washington
the regulatory impulse is so strong when
you see an uber or a lift oh that's a
taxicab company let's let's lap all the
taxicab regulations on it Airbnb that's
a hotel company same thing in the
telecom sector too let's try to make
sure horn all these legacy regulations
onto these new companies and to maintain
those or legacy regulations on the
established companies my goal is pretty
simple to just modernize our regulations
to reflect the marketplace we're in
unlearn what you have learned when it
comes to telecom policy and you'll
unleash all kinds of innovation and
investment that ultimately benefits
consumers we don't want to
disincentivize companies from competing
and innovating because ultimately the
consumer welfare there's a consumer
offer is what's at stake here
more importantly than any of this where
we're yet with the new Star Wars yeah so
this I haven't really been a big fan
except for I will say I thought force
awakens was okay robe one yeah that was
awesome I need more force really yeah
about that ending scene those amazing I
mean it really feeds into that four
scene in the episode four and it's but
no force awakens was pretty good I
thought say well you give me two hours
of the last five minutes of rogue one
two hours of just an onslaught then I'm
throw that alright let's not get lost
there because I sense we could probably
do that for
a couple hours so a lot of this is sort
of just fighting the Washington machine
right like John the machine itself is
designed to create regulation right so
they see something like uber come out
now everyone loves uber and it's
changing the business but now you've got
all these interests with the taxi
companies and then suddenly you then
have to fight the impulse to yeah
basically crush them - yeah that that's
a pretty amazing position it's very
difficult and there are two very
powerful forces in Washington one is
regulatory inertia that it's very easy
to maintain the rules on the books
because they've always been on the books
and they should always therefore be on
the books but the other one is some of
the entrenched interests that say look
no matter any regulatory change is going
to disadvantage somebody and so they
will complain those people who are
affected will have a disproportionate
voice they'll be very loud about it and
so that's part of the challenge as well
to try to have the long term value of
the greater number of people in mind
when we make our decisions so let's talk
about that a little bit like the the
lobbying situation how much of the
influence that hits you is lobbyists
from either telecommunications companies
or free speech organizations or whatever
it might be yeah every sector I think
has has a grievance or to share with the
agency but our goal is just a little bit
about how it works so you're in your
office your assessment says dr you got a
couple meetings today and now you know
some lobbyists are coming in like what
what is the process actually like so
yeah I have a lot of meetings every day
that I'm in the office in Washington and
what often happens is that people sit on
my couch very much like we're sitting
here and what they'll tell me oh gee
you're doing a great job on this and
that and this and that we are all in
favor of this we are big free market
advocates on this particular issue week
and it's amazing how many times that
happens I've needed a roundtable
recently out on the road and it was
striking one of the biggest innovations
we've introduced we have a ten billion
dollar subsidy fund known as the
Universal Service Fund typically this
consisted of cutting checks to rural
telephone companies and saying you vaya
con Dios we hope you build broadband
networks with this funding one of the
major innovations I introduced about two
years ago when I just got on board was
instead of just cutting a check let's
have an auction a reverse auction where
all kinds of companies
different technologies have to compete
for this funding and there's a downward
pressure on prices it's technologically
neutral saves the taxpayer money
Yatta Yatta it much more efficient at
serving the cause I can sit in this
roundtable and they said we love all of
the stuff you're doing on the universal
service fund it might be helpful though
decart me to exempt us from the auction
mechanism because it just be because
look I understand from their business
perspective it makes sense but my goal
it can't be to vindicate any private
interest is not to vindicate any private
interest its to uphold the public
interest and that's going to make people
unhappy in many cases because many
business plans might not survive or
might not thrive in an environment where
that kind of competition has is embraced
by the regulator so let's back up a
little bit to your philosophy again
which basically you're saying free
markets you want them to do as much as
possible yeah you're the guy that has to
come in and give some regulation around
the public good what do you think would
happen so this may be is this is like
sort of the purist libertarian approach
what do you think would happen if you've
just basically the regulations just all
disappeared and just the free market
just was allowed to do whatever whatever
it wants related to all of these issues
around communication like what question
would happen I think it's that's a very
good question so I'm gonna move this
because we leave this the entire time
the amount of memes that will come out
that you had an hour-long conversation
with a recent bar on the table my god
it's gonna it's become the MacGuffin or
innovator buffs out there we're gonna
have it later
you promised well let's just see how it
finishes that okay all right well we'll
see how it goes but but your question
was about the lack of regulation
altogether and I'm not one who says
necessarily that we need to scrap
everything for example in terms of
setting spectrum policy it's important
for us to coordinate among different
government agencies in the private
sector but I do think that it would be
an interesting experiment some of these
areas of the government got out of the
business give you one example back in
1975 one of my predecessors instituted
rule prohibiting newspapers and
broadcast for TV and radio stations from
combining because that was seem to be
that rental the competition does anyone
really think in 2019 that local
newspapers write local radio stations or
the dominant force in any particular
market especially some of the smaller
markets I don't really think so so if
got rid of regulations there I don't
think would lead to all this
consolidation to the contrary it would
enable them to compete with the googles
and the Facebook's and the Pandora's and
Spotify and others who are out there
distributing information and so that to
me at least I think it's an interesting
thought exercise and as that denominator
so to speak grows as more people start
to compete in the same space I think
it's important for government to have an
intellectually honest assessment of what
competition is that denominator is much
broader than broadcast radio for example
it's all those streaming services and
podcasts and all the rest of it that
people the people just wanna consume
information information honestly is the
denominator in many cases so I I think
there's probably certain amount of you
were listening to this cone alright he's
down with the free markets he's my name
is the light touch when possible yeah
how was this guy nominated by Obama this
sounds more like say a conservative or a
Republican approach can you talk about
that yeah so traditionally commissioners
who are in the minorities of the FCC I
should have backed up the five
commissioners I mentioned three of whom
are of the president's party two are of
the minority party the party had to
power so I was nominated in 2011
confirmed in 2012 for one of the
minority party seats and by tradition
going back a couple of decades the
leader of the part of the Senate leader
of the party out of power it makes a
recommendation to the White House on who
those minority commissioners should be
and so in my case
Senator McConnell recommended to
President Obama we recommended sheet for
this slot some phil has to say it's okay
even though you're the ones getting the
minority slot right interesting yeah so
it's a very interesting still has the
power to stop that minority person
theoretically yes so unfortunately I
fell through the cracks ed yeah I had
good friends on both sides of the aisle
and I confirm unanimously so it wasn't
an issue but it's a very interesting
model of governance and I think a lot of
the cabinet departments of course which
is just a secretary have a very
different model where it's more of a
single person in charge of the agency so
how much then of your job is
coordinating with the president I mean
two things really so I'm from what I can
understand it sounds like Trump is
probably more in line with your your
philosophy around this but does that
even matter that much did you see a big
difference from when Obama was there to
know
that's an interesting point we are
actually an independent agency so once
we are confirmed by the Senate we're off
to the races we don't answer to anybody
we are independent from the
administration independent from Congress
although we of course I assume they can
create headaches for you oh absolutely
and there are certain issues especially
when it comes to security for example or
some spectrum issues where we have to
coordinate with say the Department of
Defense or the National Security Council
where we do work with White House and
administration agencies all the time but
one of the things that the
president-elect told me when I
interviewed for the job in January 2017
was I'm giving you this job because I
believe you're going to do a terrific
things do the job you know I'm trusting
you with this responsibility because I
know you'll execute as you see fit and
we'll back you up 100% of the way and so
that's been largely what it's all been
about we've been pursuing a lot of
different initiatives and they've been
supportive as especially on things like
5g where we think it's a national
priority not just an FCC priority for
America to lead the world in this
next-generation technology so what's
happening with igu right now because I
think now in LA it's in certain spots I
am seeing 5g it just pops up on my phone
and I remember you know I was traveling
around last year that certain cities I
would get it and I'd be like whoa I
didn't even know this was a thing so how
does that actually work what you guys
are trying to build a nationwide network
yeah so if I've G is going to be
tremendous 100 times faster speeds and
4G if not quicker than that much lower
latency and quicker responsiveness of
the network and also all kinds of
applications we can't even dream of so
we're just in the early stages right now
the wireless carriers are doing some
deployments in major cities including
Los Angeles and we're hopeful that's
going to ramp up in the future I think
we're gonna have 92 commercial
deployments across the country by the
end of this year many more coming and so
our goal is just put the building blocks
in place for companies to innovate that
involve spectrum we're getting a lot
more spectrum in the commercial market
place held a big auction in January and
other one finished up in May the biggest
auction in American history is going to
be on December 10th and this year alone
we're gonna push more spectrum in the
commercial marketplace and is held by
every mobile broadband provider combined
when I came into office and so huge
influx of supply on the infrastructure
side - we're modernizing our rules to
recognize that small cells essentially
infrastructure that's no bigger than say
that basketball shouldn't have to jump
through the same regulatory hoops it's a
200-foot cell tower and that's the kind
of thing that has real pop here in LA in
particular just yesterday morning I was
visiting a site where the
these small cells in a lower income
neighborhood thanks in part to the
regulatory streamlining that we've done
and the city of La believe it or not has
done they have now have the regular
counseling you the city of may is
helping I've got to say mayor Garcetti
has been a terrific partner on this
issue other cities may have raised a
little few more roadblocks but those
cities that are forward-thinking that
want their citizens to benefit from 5g
or adopting this more modern approach to
infrastructure deployment so overall I
think the United States is poised to
lead but there are other countries too
particularly China that would love to
seize the lead for themselves and so
we're in an implicit competition I think
with many countries and regions around
the world yeah so right before we
started we talked about this issue with
how China deals with regulation
differently and there there's strengths
and weaknesses to it can you explain
that a bit cuz I think it's it's a
really fascinating flip on the way we
talk about a lot of these issues
it is so China of course is not a
democracy Beijing can dictate not just
what Policy Priorities the government
should follow but also require all
provinces all localities to fall into
line and so of course since they don't
deserve the same democratic niceties we
do in this case they can simply Fiat we
want to lead the world in 5g that means
we're going to pick the companies that
create the equipment and subsidize them
we're going to make sure that our
wireless carriers can deploy at scale
they don't have to jump through these
regulatory hoops and we are otherwise
going to take the steps necessary to
free up spectrum and do the other things
necessary for 5g success so that kind of
sounds good at some level right right
but there are of course some concerns
for those who share democratic values
such as the United States compared daily
here we have not just federal regulatory
approval that's required state and local
regulatory approval that's required in
many cases but also under a
long-standing system that the FCC said
it many years ago any one of the 573
federally recognized Indian tribes also
can have a bite at the regulatory Apple
so one of the points I've made is that
let's try to modernize that framework to
say that there's a consistent level of
regulation especially if you're a
smaller company you don't have the
lawyers and accountants compliance
officers to jump through all of these
four different layers or review and to
the extent the capital is scarce and
work crews don't have to be hired and
networks don't have to be built I don't
want that innovative spirit to be
directed to other parts of the world
where you can deploy at scale and that's
part of the reason why we've been trying
to work with localities like LA to
update that framework
make it more streamlined and just easier
and cheaper to build these networks so
in effect while China can just say
alright we're doing this and no local
province can do anything about it and
and while that may work for now like it
may make the process faster for now
while you have to deal with the local
states and all that yeah in the long
term it probably hurts their ability to
innovate because it's all coming from
the top right you guys have more of a
slog to fight through now but the hope
is that you're creating the the
groundwork sort of to allow as much
competition as possible that through the
SL companies basically exactly right and
part of the reason why I want this
regulatory modernization is not just to
be able to compete with other countries
but also because we've recognized and
this is one of the truths that hardly
ever gets recognized in Washington that
heavy-handed regulation and multiple
levels of regulation disproportionately
affect smaller companies it's the larger
companies that don't have the compliance
freeze that have the compliance
resources and they can jump through a
lot of these hoops it sure it will cost
them money but they actually have the
resources to comply we don't want to
squeeze out some of the smaller
competitors and especially in the
technology space we're trying to
encourage a lot more companies to enter
this space we haven't talked about space
itself yet satellite companies and fixed
wireless companies and some of these
newer companies they might not be able
to get off the ground
if that regulatory framework is so
onerous that they can't raise capital
they can't hire the lawyers and they can
never deploy a product yeah alright so
I'm obviously gonna want to spend a lot
more time talking about the pure tech
side of this in the Silicon Valley
Savage is not as you said everyone
thinks it's sort of your job but it's
not quite your job but wait let's just
do the the space thing for a minute
because now it's really interesting
because it quite literally is the next
frontier if not the final frontier how
in the world do you sit down with people
and you know you have you have
government people now trying to deal
with the ideas that Elan musk and all
these people are coming in with we're
privatizing a lot of the space stuff how
do you even come to a basic place where
you can say well you can you can kind of
do this and I want you to be free but we
can't totally do that I mean how does
that conversation even go it's it's
fascinating first of all it's just
intellectually fascinating to me I've
always loved space and the the
innovation that's happening in space
right now is just unprecedented I mean
the launches they're able to do using
reusable rockets have really decreased
the cost element to launching
these things into space I mean Elan
literally sent a Tesla into it just just
because he could do it like you didn't
have a regulation around that that you
can just send a car into space there was
no you didn't want to didn't follow with
the dart purview but certain other
things do fall within our purview so
over the last two and a half years that
we were the first administration to
approve what are called non
geostationary satellite orbit
constellations NGS knows but essentially
a lot of satellites that are being
launched by companies like SpaceX and
oneweb and it probably cup or Amazon in
the future
hundreds are not thousand of these
satellites in low Earth orbits not deep
into space but lower in the Earth's
orbit so that they can beam internet
access services at a speed in a price
point they'd be comparable to what you'd
get from a terrestrial provider and my
position here is very reflective of
those principles we talked about from
the beginning instead of preemptively
regulating deciding okay you can launch
but all of you know we're not going to
let you do it trying to pick a business
case or a business plan that's going to
work and letting them take the first
crack we're taking a more market-based
approach let's allow all of them to
launch it was various stages using
certain parameters for orbital safety
and whatnot and you'll see what happens
let's let the market the aggregated
decisions of consumers decide which one
will succeed and some of them might you
never know it could be a residential
broadband product some of them very
different they want to do industrial
internet of things I met recently with a
company that just wants to deploy 150
satellites around the globe and they
want to sign up customers like you say
the Department of Defense it has
military all around the world and they
just need essentially low bandwidth
services just to let people know where
the troops are at any given point in
time we want all of them to be able to
succeed in space and so yeah you don't
really think about the orbital safety
portion of this as you know I do but
happen so that's just like no matter
what happens you guys almost always need
another office to open right I mean is
that sort of how it works yeah all right
I want them to put the satellites up
there we want to get people internet as
fast as possible and it's cheapest
possible it's all good and then someone
probably walks in is like you know we
got make sure these satellites aren't
crashing into each other and then you
have to do what do you do you do another
study I mean do you
what are you mapping out there that's a
good question so that's it goes to the
early question answer what if there were
no regulation so here is where I think
there is a base level of regulation
that's really important especially in
the space environment for those of you
who saw gravity via Sandra Bullock
things just spinning around laughing
exactly because that stuff lasts for
thousands of thousands of years
especially if they don't descend in the
atmosphere and burn up and so we want to
make sure that that space environment is
safe for everybody and so one of the
things I kicked off about a year ago
let's see how should we update our
orbital debris rules they were first
adopted in 2004 but back then we didn't
have a lot of satellites up in space
we're talking about a lot more stuff in
space and so accordingly I think our
orbital debris rules need to be updated
so we're in the middle of conversation
now about how should we think about
updating those rules requiring companies
to be safe should they have 2d or '''but
on a certain schedule you said certain
technology that kind of things yeah so I
assume you'd prefer that everything has
some sort of like time limit up there or
something so that eventually that it
doesn't just become space garbage yeah
that's one of the Futurama or something
yeah exactly that's one of the things
we're thinking about is from the very
time limit should it be a built in
technology so some of these satellites
can do orbit automatically after a
certain period of time or if there is a
failure they will automatically deorbit
things like that and so ultimately we
want to make sure that everybody's can
succeed in space in the long run we
don't want to do like I said in any of
these orbital slots if you have debris
that's a generational problem not just a
multi-year problem how much of this is
sort of long-term thinking say the way
you would talk about the climate change
situation so it's sort of like you can
you can plot a certain degree but no
matter how much you plot other countries
I mean you just reference China other
countries are just going to do things
the way they want and how complicated
that makes your job its meaning you
could do everything exactly perfectly
right and still if some other country
decides to do whatever they want you
still you still have all of those
problems it's that is a problem so
there's a lot of international
coordination that has to happen
especially when it comes to orbital
debris we're always working with some of
the other countries agencies to make
sure that we're all on the same page and
there are international organizations
that deal specifically with this in fact
shortly coming up and Egypt there's a
big quadrennial every four years they
have this conference and to talk about
spectrum issues and one of the issues is
what spectrum should be available for
satellite companies and so in that
context we're always talking about being
on the same page on things like orbital
debris and in spectrum allocation but I
think you raised a really good point is
that we could do everything correctly
but other countries
are looking to take the lead on things
like artificial intelligence machine
learning or blockchain or quantum
computing and we don't have jurisdiction
over all of it but to the extent we can
we want to make sure we advance the u.s.
leadership because I do you think that
there are some first mover advantages to
countries and to sectors that really
show that they're willing to take the
lead yeah all right let's let's take
this back to this planet for a moment
all right let's let's really dive into
the to the tech stuff because it's
obviously near and dear to me now first
can you explain how this is not fully
your jurisdiction because this is this
is one of the interesting things where
I've mentioned right before we started
you've got you know elizabeth warren on
the left calling for big tech regulation
you've got tucker carlson on the right
calling for big tech regulation and it's
like all right that's a strange that's
that little horseshoe thing that
everyone's going well how did this end
up happening that these two people on it
they wanted for very different reasons
but can you first explain how this isn't
exactly your jurisdiction cuz I think I
think everyone sort of thinks it is when
they say government involvement I think
they mean the FCC yeah they often do
think the FCC and especially in the
context of some of the more politically
salient issues like net neutrality they
would so in a nutshell
under current law as Congress has set it
forth for many many years the FCC has
jurisdiction over the network's
themselves the guts of the networks we
don't necessarily have jurisdiction or
we don't have jurisdiction over the
content companies that get right over
those networks and so we don't need
right so the infrastructure basically
the pipes yes exactly so the
infrastructure not so much the content
that goes over those pipes and so that's
the fundamental distinction to the
extent that an agency does have
jurisdiction is primarily the Federal
Trade Commission and the Department of
Justice each of which is now taking a
look at some of those tech companies
yeah what is your I mean I don't know if
you can speak to this as as you know the
chairman of the FCC but what do you sort
of see as the right way to deal with
these the censorship issues you know the
shadow banning Algar and the
manipulations you know suppressing
search results all of these things do
you have a general philosophy on how to
deal with this I think that obviously
these companies have thrived with a more
light touch approach but a couple of
years ago I did flag before it was cool
I will note by the way I did flag the
fact that consumers legitimately had
some concerns as
did lawmakers about the lack of
transparency on how some of these
companies operated we don't have insight
into how facebook orders articles in its
newsfeed we didn't have insight into how
Twitter might decide to organize Twitter
moments or with Google and YouTube and
we didn't have insight into D
monetization and things like that and I
said look we need to have consistent
level of regulation across the entire
internet economy it shouldn't matter
whether you're a network operator or a
content provider for example when it
comes to privacy as an online consumer I
don't care whether it's a network
company or a content provider that has
my sensitive information I want that
information to be protected and I called
a couple of years ago for a conversation
about how should we think about the tech
sector these some of these tech giants
that have been completely unregulated
and now it's interesting to see as you
mentioned people from across the
political spectrum are reaching this
sort of odd consensus that something
needs to be done what that something is
I don't quite know and it's up to
Congress to say but it is interesting
how the conversation has evolved over
the last couple of years is this
becoming one of the weird ones that you
sort of referenced before we're in a
weird way the the big boys in the game
they kind of do want regulation now
because they know that that they'll be
able survive Google's got a lot of
lawyers but that the new guys coming up
once there's more regulation they're
gonna have to hit certain benchmarks to
do certain things and they just won't be
able to do it and also possibly that the
problems are now so huge especially
around free speech that it's like please
regulate us that way we don't have to
think about the problems it is very
curious that that's how things have
changed so some of those companies were
strongly advocating for net neutrality
regulations coming from Washington
heavy-handed regulations applied to some
of their network operator rivals when
California in particular passed a law on
this subject those companies were very
much behind it but now the table
somewhat turns the California's passed a
stringent privacy law those very same
companies are coming to Washington
telling Congress we need a federal
privacy law in order to get rid of this
patchwork of state regulation and I
always say under the well-established
precedent of goose vs. gander you can't
have it both ways you have to be able to
be intellectually consistent on this
issue and that's part of the reason why
on net neutrality on privacy on any of
these issues let's just have an open
intellectually honest conversation about
how to establish a consistent level of
regulation that protects consumers and
competition across the entire internet
economy I have to write that one down
make a note of that one to check that
one out later I don't have a copyright
on it yet but just stay tuned
okay so let's back up I want because you
mentioned that neutrality a couple times
now about a year and a half ago or so
and net neutrality disappeared if you
were paying attention to the sort of
mainstream take on it
this was it World War three was starting
the universe over nobody was going to
get video everybody was going to be
throttled you know corporations we're
gonna take over here we are it's amazing
so can you just all right can you
absolutely just for the people that
really want like the cleanest clearest
explanation so we can clip this purse
perfectly what was that neutrality and
what actually happened so net neutrality
involves the basic question of how if at
all should the FCC treat Internet access
should it regulate it under what is
called title 2 which was the 1930s
regulations that were developed to
regulate Ma Bell the old telephone
monopoly or should we regulate the
internet under title 1 the more
market-based approach that governed the
internet from 1996 until 2015 my view is
the market-based approach service very
well we got to 1.5 trillion dollars of
network investment companies like some
of those that we've mentioned becoming
giants from startups and consumers
benefiting from all that innovation and
at the end of the day I look at the
evidence that's in the record when we
made our decision in December of 2017 I
kept track of some of those predictions
you're going to have to pay $5 per tweet
you're not going to be allowed to post
on Instagram one of my favorites the
Senate Democratic caucus Twitter account
said the internet will work one word at
a time or one of my favorites this is
the end of the Internet as we know it
well fast forward to now internet speeds
in the United States on average are up
over 50% network investment in 2018 was
up three billion dollars the second and
consecutive increase more fiber was
deployed in 2018 than in any year since
they've been keeping records and venture
capital funding startups has set a
record in 2018 and one wouldn't expect
that if these Internet service providers
were in fact acting as a gatekeeper
choking off innovation and so to those
critics out there I would say the record
is clear the Internet is open and more
open than ever and thanks to our
decision more people than ever before
faster than ever before can hate tweet
their favorite SEC chair
I think it's a testament to our success
right so you got an unbelievable about
oh my god during that time yeah no
kidding was that that might have led you
to want to regulate some of it's a
little bit more stuck with your ideals
yeah no I did it there was a lot of
pressure of the on the other side no
question about it and a personal threats
made against me and my family and even
the agency itself there are people in
jail today for threatening my family in
the agency and so but at the end of the
day I really had the conviction that we
were doing the right thing and you know
I've got a I quote buy my computer and I
see it every single day when I power up
it is from Churchill back in the 20s and
it said you hear this young men and
women and proclaim it far and wide the
earth is yours and the fullness thereof
be kind but be fierce you are needed now
more than ever before
take up the mantle of change for now is
your time and I know it sounds cheesy
but I really do try to embrace that
ethos that you've got to you've got to
know what you believe and you've got to
execute on that belief to the best of
your ability and take the arrows that
come with it is it going to be popular
always no not at all I'm I understand
that a lot of people still are angry
about this decision but at the end of
the day I've got the long term in mind
and the long term is one in which the
digital divide closes everyone's
connected to the Internet the Internet
is free and open and that's the vision
that we're going to continue to execute
do you think just to sort of give the
people that wanted to keep net
neutrality in place to give the devil is
do let's say do you think that it's just
a fundamental misunderstanding of what
companies do I mean the fear seem to be
that if you if you don't regulate them
in this way
that you know one company will slow down
Netflix and the other one will speed up
their own broadband service and all
these things and there is some like
there's some like initial thought that
kind of makes sense there like you would
want to hurt your competitors if you're
in several businesses and you'd want to
help your partners but that that's not
really how competition works and I guess
everything that you just laid out is
sort of proof of that I mean yeah you
think that they just sort of
fundamentally misunderstand economics or
something like that I think I understand
the concerns they might have in the
abstract but the two things I always try
to emphasize to allay those concerns are
number one I support Congress
putting on the page in the modern era
what the rules of the road should be I
mean I would it's a one-page bill
honestly the Congress gonna pass
tomorrow
no blocking of lawful content on the
internet no throttling of lawful content
no any competitive paid prioritization
transparency make sure every Internet
service provider documents all its
business and network management
practices for everyone to see I've just
outlined a 99% supportable bill but
that's never going to happen because
what such thing is a one-page paper come
on you gotta add in what like 5,000 more
pages all the weird videos that have
something to do with farming exactly but
this is a very simple bill that I would
support I think most members of Congress
would support but the political impulses
from those who really rapidly want
heavy-handed regulation they're never
going to allow that to happen the second
thing I emphasize is look Andy antitrust
and competition law has long been a very
steadfast protector for of competition
in this area the FTC and the Department
of Justice in particular the internet
didn't die from 1996 to 2015 when we had
this exact same framework to the
contrary it thrived with the
market-based approach and just think
about what the internet would have been
if we treated it like Ma Bell they would
have an internet that was just as
reliable as Amtrak as popular as the
post office as efficient as the DMV that
is the model that some people want to
return to and to me that's not good
enough American consumers deserve better
than that have you I'm sure you've heard
about this sort of platform versus
publisher it's about the stupidest
question I've ever asked them going to
go I'm gonna go out on a limb and assume
you've heard about this debate so for me
as a guy that wants as little regulation
as possible so I totally hear your your
philosophy on this the platform vers
publisher what is starting to make sense
to me this is a place where I could
start seeing a need for regulation
because if you're just a platform then
you should you should have to do all the
things that you want in your one well
you know your one pager but if you're a
publisher then you have those extra
responsibilities yet in a weird way the
platform say Twitter YouTube Facebook
are behaving like publishers and not
platforms how complex is all of this to
gun pack it's it's exceptionally complex
and one of the fascinating things to
watch from my vantage point is on
Capitol Hill you're now
seeing Republicans and Democrats openly
wondering should we change the laws
sheila's hold hearings to examine how we
should change the laws to accommodate
this new understanding and it's
everything seems to be up for grabs
right now and I'm not sure how it's
going to play out but that debate of
platform versus publisher is something
that I think was pretty much unthinkable
just five years ago so I'm not sure
where it's going to go but we're
certainly watching it do you think it's
possible that there are certain things
that the government is just no longer
equipped to handle like that the power
and the amount of information the amount
of technology that Google let's say
controls right now is so awesome and
unprecedented that the idea that a
government Regulatory Commission could
actually harness it fully understand it
and fully guide it in the right way that
that almost is impossible that's a
really good thing to think about I
suppose yeah but I mean do you think
that is possible that these companies
have grown in ways like the amount of
power that Google has is way more than
Ma Bell had in 1930 and they and
government obviously changes much slower
than a technology company can that's a
good question I think I mean I have to
think about it a little deeper I would
say it at first cut I do think the tools
of antitrust and competition law are
fairly well suited to deal with
companies that may have market power
amines are well you know the standard
oils of yesteryear are you could just as
easily that that framework it just as
easily applied to the tech giants of
today and to evaluate whether or not
they are posing an anti-competitive
threat what it would say is the central
problem we haven't yet wrestled with is
that the pace of technological
innovation is quickening if anything and
we're now rapidly dealing with and not
just laws that are out of date but a
Congress that in an regulatory structure
that isn't equipped to deal nimbly with
some of the challenges to give you one
example official recognition technology
and we are now seeing a lot of people
wondering well should we ban or shall we
regulate facial recognition technology
how does it work or cryptocurrencies I
you see regulators struggling with how
should we think about this is it another
financial instrument that we should
regulate under the old laws or should we
just come up with something new and
across all of these different sectors
the pace is so fast that by the time we
even understand what it is
is it's just almost too late to pass
regulations because the marketplace has
moved beyond it so I think that is one
of the central problems that we haven't
yet grappled with yeah is the other part
just that administration's change pretty
quickly I mean yeah we don't know who
the president is gonna be in about a
year and a half from now we don't and
the next person could come in and is
your term is that just on the the
decision of the president or didn't know
interior oh so i'm as i every chairman
is a commissioner so I have a
commissioner term that ends in 2022
and but by law the president has to
designate whoever the chairman is any
given point in time so so yeah I do I
have a term that runs independent of the
presidential administration that happens
to be in power but technically the next
president could just like you I can take
you out of that term exactly so how much
of your consideration has to do with
just the political realities it to me
zero one of the great things about being
an independent agency is that we make
the decision that we think is the right
one and that generally speaking our
initiatives have been nonpartisan in
nature I mean to me Utley it's getting
broadband to rural Americans and tribal
Americans it's not a Republican issue or
democratic issue it's just an American
issue getting people with disabilities
access to technology helping people in
our akane ravaged areas it's not a
partisan issue as well and 5g is the
national imperative so a lot of these
things are actually bipartisan in nature
or nonpartisan I would say and so to me
at least that's how I've tried to
embrace the job and the other thing that
goes unremarked in Washington at least
as far as we can tell I'm the first
chairman in history ever to ask each one
of the commissioners Republican and
Democrat to take leadership to speak for
the agency on an issue of importance
traditionally the chairman essentially
hogs all the responsibility for himself
or herself but I've tried to delegate a
lot of that to make sure that all of
them feel empowered that's good for them
but it's also good for the agency to
show that look we're not a political
agency that rises or Falls based on
where the political winds may happen to
take us you must be pretty enthused that
like things like this exist for you to
get your message out versus in Mauldin
to the extent that somebody might want
to hear some wonky stuff from the FCC
chairman it was basically done on a
5-minute Sunday morning talk show and
it's like now you can actually really
expand on it and that's why I'm so
grateful to outlets like this one I tell
you is somebody I mean a lot of your
viewers are probably much younger than
me but as somebody who grew up
in the late 70s and early 80s in rural
Kansas there were very few ways to get
information from the outside world
virtually none to get information
translated from you to get your voice
heard right and so to go from that where
we were 30 40 years ago to now where
essentially the Internet is democratized
speech in a way that was unthinkable
it's incredible to me I mean one example
I always use is I was the first FCC
Commissioner on Twitter back in 2012
when I joined some my colleague said
this is crazy this is you shouldn't be
doing this but now it's enabled me to
get the message out to people who are
never gonna be able to come to
Washington or hire somebody to come to
Washington on their behalf and it's had
a real impact on my work and my ability
to get my voice out there a few issues
that I've championed that have been a
result of people tweeting at me and I
learned more about the issue when we end
up taking action that helps in this one
case in particular save lives of the 91
one calling system we've improved thanks
in part to a tweet I got back in
December of 2013 what was that so in
December 1st of 2013 a woman named
Carrie hunt Dunn was living in Marshall
Texas she and her three kids went to
visit her estranged husband in a hotel
room in Texas as soon as she got into
the hotel room Rosman started stabbing
her and her nine-year-old daughter raced
to the hotels rooms phone started
dialing 911 1s everybody knows but the
call didn't go through and says she
dialed 9-1-1 once again and one more
time and one more time she didn't
realize she had to dial 9 first to reach
an outside line so this story made the
local press down there somebody tweeted
the story at me and I started reading up
and I thought what does I mean that may
raise my antenna what's the situation in
911 calling around the country so two
weeks later I was on the phone with Hank
hunt who was Kerry's father
talked to him about the situation a
month later sent a letter to the CEOs
the top 10 hotel chains in the United
States as well as the Hotel and Lodging
Association a year after that I stood
next to Hank in Marshall Texas where we
updated the American public on the
progress we had made and last year I
stood with Hank in the Oval Office as
the president signed legislation named
Kerry's law after his late daughter to
establish no access code required a
legislation that would essentially allow
direct access to 911 and so to me at
least I know Twitter has pinned plus it
and widest for many many people but to
me that least that story
vindicates the power of an individual
like Hank to get a story out there and
to affect meaningful social change yeah
I mean that's pretty incredible and
actually the way you just laid it out
even with the dates I mean you guys move
pretty quick on this that doesn't sound
like a kind of governmental thing right
like yeah instead of yourself I mean I
for one thing good I think people will
appreciate whether they like or don't
like whether the policies we pursue is I
tend to be a pretty energetic person I'd
want to get things done and I haven't
impatience about me that just they
forces me to want to take action as
quick as possible so on an issue like
that which naturally it sounds right
like cuz no kid would think that they
have too many adults wouldn't realize
you have to press nine to get the
al-jabbar did you get any pushback from
the industry that was like we don't want
outside access or something like that I
mean what would what would be that got
something like there wasn't a lot of
pushback it was more well what how
difficult would it be to retrofit some
of the old telephone systems or it was
the government going to mandate specific
technology to be used and so I think
they're generally very supportive and
what I found in talking to some of the
hotel owners and phone manufacturers as
soon as they became aware of the issue
they were more than willing to make a
change in many cases it doesn't cost any
money it's essentially just flipping a
switch so to speak in terms of software
and you get rid of that access code and
to me it's really gratifying whenever I
check into a hotel room now I always
look at the phone as soon as I put down
my key and it's it's great to see you
dialed and I know to reach emergency
sources just dial nine-one-one and
millions of Americans who check into
hotel rooms will never know that the FCC
they can't could have part in that but
it goes to that point you're making
earlier that the longer-term value that
we delivered even if it doesn't get
attributed to us
I really makes me feel good to know that
we made a positive difference so you've
mentioned Twitter the good and the bad a
couple of times here we should relate
some of this to generally just the
election because I don't know if you
know this but we're in a position years
there's no idea and all of the sort of
the hate and the good and all of its
it's all kind of ramping up yeah
censorship stuff and all of that do you
guys have anything directly to do with
when people say that Russian bots were
hacking the election and manipulating
news stories and all of these things how
how much directly is does that fall
under your purview oh it doesn't
actually so we would do follow of course
just in the popular press some of the
articles in commentary that go on about
that but that would be more within the
purview of other agencies now I will say
in terms of cybersecurity we do work
with our other federal partners very
closely and so the Department of
Homeland Security in particular has an
agency in the cyber security and
infrastructure security agency sisse
and that's led by a gentleman Chris
Krebs who I work with very regularly I
just met with him last week on some of
the 5g security issues so to the extent
that the actual hacking of networks is
involved we do have a seat at the table
so to speak do you find that the other
commissioners that you have to work with
basically have a similar philosophical
leaning I think so I generally speaking
when it comes to security we're all on
the same page we want these telecoms and
networks to be secure we might have
different answers on how to get there
but ultimately I think we do share the
same goal in fact this is one of the
issues I've tapped one of my Democratic
colleagues to represent the agency at
some of these 5g security issues
precisely because I recognize that the
security of these 5g networks it's not a
Republican issue not a democratic issue
and it may raise some eyebrows why are
you chatting somebody from the other
party but I think it's important for
Americans to speak with one voice on
this issue and I'm more than happy to
share the credit if we get their ball
across the goal line that's great if he
can do it can you talk generally I think
that's a good transition to just like
what is the culture in Washington right
now not even necessarily with your job
but I think everyone's feeling this
thing that just the Machine kind of
doesn't work anymore everyone does
everything on partisan lines you just
mentioned that you you try not to do
that but just like what is the culture
someone that lives and works in
Washington you know you're you're part
of a machine that you know
administration's come and go you're
still gonna be there yeah and you know
people are always talking about that
sort of thing now like that that the
watching machine just always exists yeah
you just look at the culture a little
bit it's increasingly poisonous I may
have found that there's much more
tribalism in Washington than ever before
and I do think it's I'm not sure if the
cause or an effect of the tribalism we
see in our body politic generally
speaking but I do find it distressing a
lot of the times that some of them blow
back I'll get on Twitter has nothing to
do with me it's just oh you're in you're
part of the administration's they screw
you and
you know that kind of knee-jerk
tribalism and conversely on the other
side too it's a you know if you're on
the other if you're supporting one of
the candidates on the campaign trail yes
screw you do I don't want to have
anything to do with you and so that kind
of ethos has permeated Washington to
some extent it's it's unfortunate
because I do think that at the end of
the day there are certain things that we
did have a consensus on I mean the free
market principle it was not that long
ago that I think we had is that the most
shocking one to you because that one
seems so bizarre to me that to me it's
debating things that have have led to
all of the success that we all live in
right now and we're suddenly just
tossing it up there as if these things
should be debated it would be a close
second I would say to free speech that's
one of the issues that I think I've
often said it distinguishes American
democracy from virtually any other
society in the world today or even in
history and I always say that free
speech is not just the cold guarantee
that's on the parchment of the
Constitution it's also a culture that
emerged from many many years with great
sacrifice and it's very you know if you
have a view that is opposed to mind the
tradition of course was that was that
saying misattributed to Voltaire yeah I
may disagree with what you say but I'll
fight for the you have to right your
right to say it increasingly we see that
no people want to wall off the public
square in fact push people out of the
public square altogether if there's a
dissimilarity of views and that is
something that's extremely dangerous to
this country have you thought of one of
the interesting ideas that I've heard
related to just backing up to the
platform's themselves is that since
these are private companies that it's
almost like let them do whatever they
want basically but that then the
government could actually get involved
in creating a platform that would
respect all of the laws in the United
States and that that would be an
interesting use of government money
because it's like oh all right
Twitter can do what they want YouTube
can do what they want but what if the
government actually just had a platform
that as long as you're abiding by the
laws of the United States basically you
were allowed to be in there something
like that I kind of think about a more
deeply I guess though two of my concerns
would be number one the government
generally speaking is not well
positioned to be created operate a firm
like that and the second one would be as
we saw with the debates over the
Fairness Doctrine in the 1970s 1980s
that that doctrine was ms name for
slightly because it empowered government
officials she just
and essentially assign points based on
what side of the political ledger you're
on and that is the kind of thing that I
yeah basically unfairness doctrine I
mean people think well it sounded right
I mean it's not what they do with
everything it sounds like the Fairness
Doctrine we're gonna have it everybody's
ideas be out there equally but at the
end of the day if the market doesn't
yeah people just don't care about your
ideas why should the government be
propping you up and that's what it was
doing right yeah that's always one of my
concerns the same thing when it comes to
spending money if somebody tells me oh
this service or product is free well
sometimes the only problem with fries
that it costs too much and you have to
look at the fine print and so too when
it comes to free speech issues so I do I
do think that that's one of the issues I
have to think a little more deeply about
but that would be my instant reaction
yeah so are you are you hopeful then
that our defense of free speech will
will continue and that we're gonna you
know maintain this rare First Amendment
thing that we've got that is the
jealousy of the world I don't know I
mean I so when I travel around the
country and I've now been to all 40
states in the connell US and Puerto
Rican the Virgin Islands and you meet
people we're just trying to put food on
the table
work hard and raise their families you
get a sense of that bedrock
understanding of America's commitment to
free speech is still strong but my god
when you see some of these controversy
emerging on college campuses on internet
platforms like Twitter
it does make you worry you are we going
to have a generation of leaders that is
committed to that ideal and I don't know
I mean I hope so and I think it does I
did I think it does rub a lot of people
of goodwill on both sides the wrong way
to know that there are certain correct
views and only those views should be her
in the public square because you know
one day your views might be viewed as
incorrect and so know the feeling I
don't know I I guess this might be the
naive kanzen entry but I really do feel
optimistic that that instinct that runs
deep in the American psyche is when it
went out in the long run but there are
some very determined opponents on the
other side to be sure so we talked about
a couple of the future things here so
we're building this 5g Network we talk
about space a little bit but just to
wrap us up nicely
what else should we be thinking about
what are the other things that are on
the horizon for you guys that maybe the
average person isn't thinking about that
if we started thinking about a little
more clearly yeah we wouldn't be in the
ODE net neutrality is going away the
world is going to
tomorrow oh let's do let's do a little
buffering for the fish so the biggest
thing will answer this right you thought
oh all right I'll give you a recess I'll
even put the recess back down there was
sort of this sort of high Bolivian
private he's gonna get you know where my
friend yeah I think in conjunction with
the great work we're doing on 5g and
closing the digital divide the one thing
I would flag for people is how that
interacts with artificial intelligence
and machine learning the networks of the
future are going to be smart networks
it's not going to be a person operating
locally managing a network it's going to
be software using algorithms to decide
how best to optimize that network and
what are things been doing we just held
the first ever forum in the FCC on
artificial intelligence machine learning
last December and I've been working with
a lot of entrepreneurs on this to try to
figure out what is the future how is
this going to not just the automation of
jobs but how will it make us smarter for
example if you're talking about wireless
sensors that patients might wear even
when they're not in the hospital and
those sensors could transmit a very low
bandwidth amounts of information your
vital signs and whatnot and an algorithm
can identify to could analyze it very
quickly to determine if you need if a
healthcare provider needs to intervene
quicker that's the kind of thing we're
looking at in the future or same thing
when it comes to even things like
precision agriculture believe it or not
incredibly connected farms that are
gonna require AI and machine learning
tools to figure out you buys in the
square foot where do we need to apply
fertilizer and where don't we need to
apply fertilizer I mean across all of
these industries AI machine learning is
gonna have a huge transformative effect
and I don't know what the future is but
I do think it's important for us to
think about it and I didn't mean to
gloss over the automation factor that's
another thing as well that I hear some
concern about if you're a long-haul
trucker or even a lawyer or a pharmacist
increasingly those jobs are getting
disrupted yeah I do think it's important
to have a conversation about the future
of work that's necessarily the fcc's
bailiwick but I do think it's a larger
social phenomenon that some people are
worried about some people are optimistic
about and I'm not sure where the
conversation will go but you know since
you've made a Yoda reference before I
really though you were gonna drop a
Skynet Terminator but I mean really that
that yes
like how much power will we give to the
machines and does the day come when yeah
suddenly you know they're in charge and
then they go well the humans should
probably have less power
yes I'm joking with one of my friends in
a day I know if you saw Wally but yeah
if you're gonna be like Wally or matrix
at the worst case you know Wally where
they do all the work for us what matrix
were essentially batteries for everybody
else but it's a I mean I'm pretty sure
we're in some mix of both of those right
now it's turtle all the way down it's
been a pleasure chatting with you thanks
for coming in and you guys can follow
chairman Pye on Twitter tell them
everything that you think about net
neutrality the good bad and the ugly I
apologize at a Jeep i FCC if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell